هواوي تتصدر واجهه المخاوف الامريكيه من
جديد تحضيرات من التجسس والحدود التي يمكن
ان تطولها الشركات الصينيه التكنولوجيه
والتي قد تمس الامن القومي الامريكي
واجهته الولايات المتحده بالحظر لتمنع بيع
وشراء معدات الاتصالات التي تصنعها شركه
صينيه منها هواوي وز تي اي اعضاء الهيئه
فرضه بالاجماع قواعد جديده لحمايه البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه وفق تعبيرهم
الهيئه ملزمه بحمايه امننا القومي من خلال
التاكد من ان معداتي الاتصالات غير
الموثوقه غير مصرح باستخدامها داخل حدودنا
ونحن نواصل هذا العمل هنا قرروا الهيئه لم
يقتصر على التراخيص المستقبليه للمعدات بل
يحمل احتمالا كبيرا بالغاء التصاريح
السابقه والتي تعمل تلك الشركات على ضوءها
في الولايات المتحده هواوي وزد تي اي تيرا
لم تدلي باي تعليق حول قرار الحظر بالرغم
من انها كانت قد اكدت من قبل ان معدتها لا
تستخدم لايصال اي معلومات للحكومه الصينيه
الا ان شركه هيك فيجن التي كانت على لائحه
الحظر ايضا اكدت انها ستواصل العمل ضمن
القوانين الامريكيه هذا القرار لا يساهم
بشيء لحمايه الامن القومي الامريكي ولكنه
سيكون اكثر ضررا وتكلف لشركات الصغيره في
الولايات
والمستهلكين الاف
العلاقه بين البلدين وصفتها الولايات
المتحده على لسان خارجيتها قبل الان بانها
منافسه لا يجب ان تتحول لصراع الا ان
القرارات الجديده التي اطلقتها واشنطن لي
اول مره تحمل اتهامات واضحه بمحاوله
التجسس على الاسرار القوميه الامريكيه ما
قد يخلق التوترا اكبر بين العملاقين
الامريكي والصيني الى عمر العربيه